elisabeth guigou flou le ministre de la
justice a annoncé la création d'un
contrat d'union sociale il s'agit de
donner un cadre juridique aux couples
homosexuels notamment ces couples qui
n'ont pas accès au mariage c'était l'un
des engagements de la campagne
électorale valérie fournier jean paul
chaussée sa vie de couple va changer
juridiquement le contrat d'union social
va reconnaître l'existence légale de
tous les couples homosexuels
un contrat qui mettra fin à des
situations souvent douloureuse en cas de
décès on n'assistera plus enfin à des
situations familiales conflictuelles ou
le partenaire était pouvait se retrouver
ce projet totalement par la fiole de
l'autre le nouveau gouvernement a donc
tenu sa promesse électorale
l'union hors mariage de deux personnes
aura maintenant à 7 juridique mais les
associations homosexuelles
combien être vigilante car le contrat du
nom social n'inclut pas le cas des
couples binationaux ni celui des
fonctionnaires en cas de mutation d'un
des deux partenaires
et puis surtout ce contrat n'est pas un
mariage si on se base sur un principe
d'égalité des droits
demain on réclamera le droit au mariage
par exemple où le droit à l'adoption
le droit la situation artificielle les
femmes célibataires particulier des
lesbiennes et cetera et cetera un peu à
l'image de ce qui se passe dans les
autres pays européens
avec ce contrat du lien social la france
ne suit pas encore les exemples
américains et surtout scandinaves où les
mariages homosexuels sont autorisés mais
elle reconnaît aujourd'hui leur alliance
de coeur